las autoridades nicaragüenses continúan
la represión contra las voces de la
oposición tras la detención y el
encarcelamiento de decenas de opositores
a daniela ortega la justicia declaró
culpable hasta 18 de ellos de delitos de
conspiración o propagación de noticias
falsas con penas que van de entre 8 a 13
años de cárcel entre los detenidos se
encuentran lester alemán el líder
estudiantil quien recibió una condena de
13 años de prisión al igual que el
periodista también ex aspirante
presidencial en miguel mora familiares y
abogados de los acusados así como
organizaciones de defensa de los
derechos humanos denunciaron las
condiciones en las que se desarrollaron
estos juicios la organización de estados
américanos oea condenó la persecución y
detención arbitraria por razones
políticas en nicaragua y según datos
avalados por la corte interamericana de
derechos humanos existen al menos
170 políticos privados de su libertad en
nicaragua y para ello entonces quiero
saludar a nuestra primera invitada de
ellas a vilma núñez directora del centro
nicaragüense de derechos humanos gracias
firma por estar con nosotros en directo
américa 24 muy buen día y le pregunto
entonces cuál y qué tan grave es la
situación de los políticos opositores
presos en nicaragua
muy buenos días muchas gracias por la
por la invitación
definitivamente y los relatos son
completamente
desestabilizadores para cualquier
persona que el de seguimiento los
relatos de lo que sufren todos y cada
uno de los presos y empresas políticas
en los casos de nicaragua es inenarrable
sin embargo no puedo dejar de contestar
esta pregunta con los que hoy no tiene
absolutamente conmovido
torres un héroe de la revolución
nicaragüense
prácticamente murió en manos de la
policía
resulta de que él se enfermó
porque las condiciones que existen
dentro de las cárceles precisamente son
el caldo de cultivo
específico como para que sus organismos
con las errores pusieron atención en
secreto lo trasladan o dicen ellos a un
hospital desde el pasado 7 de diciembre
y el viernes en la noche falleció cuando
había prácticamente una negativa total y
absoluta de parte del gobierno de decir
en qué circunstancias estaba porque lo
tenían en el hospital si acaso era era
verdad la situación una negativa total y
absoluta sin embargo el sábado como a la
una y media de la tarde
el ministerio público emite un
comunicado absolutamente falso
absolutamente
mentiroso y alejado de la verdad enferma
prácticamente y si le quería preguntar
entonces en ese orden de ideas la
situación humanitaria y de salud de
todos los políticos detenidos opositores
al gobierno de daniel ortega cuál es la
situación real que han podido constatar
ustedes
porque
a quién no hay ninguna posibilidad
denunciamos corremos un riesgo que no se
puede imaginar sin embargo nos basamos
precisamente en los testimonios de los
familiares que escasamente durante todo
el tiempo 78 meses de estar preso no han
podido ver en visitas sumamente
controlada el 5 de 55 veces entonces eso
es lo que nosotros conocemos
prácticamente a visitar creando las
condiciones para que el organismo de
esta persona colapse cuatro personas de
las variantes de su vida una llamada
para bailar y estar prácticamente
incomunicada
miley es incomunicada sin ver la luz del
sol sin ver en el bus en el en la
situación verdaderamente inenarrable y
hay otros que están por ejemplo en celda
de castigo completamente reducida sin
que les pase salgan solos están
prácticamente esté sin comer
adecuadamente su comienzo no permite que
la familia me llevé la comida sólo les
están recibiendo líquido o sea
prácticamente la principal preocupación
envía a todos los presos políticos sobre
todo 11 12 de ellos que son personas de
la tercera edad con padecimiento crónico
y enfermedades previas puedan colapsar
supuestamente con un botón dilma si las
cosas a qué mecanismos pueden acceder
entonces los familiares de estos de
estas víctimas que pueden hacer para
mejorar la situación de sus familiares
detenidos
prácticamente nosotros como organismo de
derecho humano
en nicaragua lo que hacemos es recibir
la denuncia en un casco cuando tenemos
cómo recurrir ante ninguna instancia
nacional aquí no hay poder judicial que
se repetía no hay policías que den
alguna información no hay ninguna
instancia ni administrativa ni judicial
que reaccione frente a una demanda
frente a una petición lo único que nos
queda es recurrir a las instancias
internacionales
específicamente la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos
pero a distancia es lo mismo que con los
de la alta comisionada
directamente a través de los
procedimientos
vilma ya para ya para finalizar nuestra
conversación qué efecto tienen estas
organizaciones internacionales sobre el
gobierno de daniel ortega y también le
pregunto entonces cuáles son las
sanciones que la comunidad internacional
estas organizaciones pueden ejercer
sobre ortega
definitivamente no creo que este nuevo
tipo de ataduras que rebaja totalmente
los parámetros justos se conocía el
funcionamiento de las diferentes
dictaduras que se han vivido no
solamente en el continente americano
sino vengo en otro estado
para meses de crueldad de brutalidad y
haber solamente el
buscar como de final opositor político
que te está avanzando sino que hay una
prácticamente alguna decisión determinó
todas las recomendaciones todos las
medidas que ha tomado
internacionalmente estaba por este
gobierno que las ignora totalmente el
gobierno
absolutamente todos sus compromisos en
materia de derechos humanos en todos sus
compromisos internacionales en materia
de derecho internacional
nosotros consideramos que el nuevo tipo
de dictadura que está prácticamente
lanzando al mundo daniel ortega tiene a
prueba la efectividad de los mecanismos
internacionales de protección por lo que
se hace una revisión y mecanismos más
directo para que puedan tener algún
efecto real en la cancha